je vous parle souvent des plus de
médiathèques et si on les voit intégrer
dans des smartphones qu'on a encore pas
vu arriver ça c'est le Renault 9 pro de
oppo qui est aussi juste là ça je l'ai
déjà présenté c'est le poco X4 GT on a
déjà eu sur ma chaîne youtube il y a un
smartphone de oneplus que je connais pas
c'est le 10 r ACO il est sur le
médiathèque du Maine City 8100 max bon
le Xiaomi booster on connaît il y a
d'autres smartphones qu'on a pas
forcément vu arriver alors souvent il y
a les noms qui chantent quand ils
arrivent en Europe redmi le k60e on a
quoi un nikiou qui se situe juste là
vivo on a le S16 pro qui est là
uniquement pour la chaîne il vous le
marque c'est un médiathèque 8200 on a
également sur des tablettes sur la
oneplus fade nouvelle tablette de
oneplus qui tourne sur un médiathèque
demon City 9000 et on est également sur
une tablette de Lenovo qui vient ici
tourner avec un Hélio G99 j'en profite
d'être ici sur le stand de médiathèque
vous montrer un petit peu et bien ce
qu'on vient voir est-ce qu'on va pas
toujours donc c'est l'intérêt d'un salon
comme le MWC pour venir découvrir des
smartphones qu'on ne connaît pas pour
venir voir des choses qu'on voit pas
globalement donc ça c'est très très cool
il y a plein de petites nouveautés dont
je vais encore vous parler donc
accrochez-vous ça va être très sympa